[موسيقى]
صباحكم ومساكم ونهاركم فل
بتاعت انا باحب اشاركهم بصوره كثير
هاي صوره
سوداء مش عم بتشوفه فيها شيء كلنا بنحب
نتصور وكلنا بنحب نحفظ ذكريات ما يمرز
بنعيشها مع احبابنا واصحابنا وخاصه القروب
في يوم من الايام اخذتها
على العشاء قالوا لي نسرين بدنا نروح
نتعشى مع بعض في مكان كثير حلو اكله كثير
زاكي وقعدت خرافيه
زي ما قلنا يوم عشره وبنلبس وبنطلع لبست
نسرين وترصاد طلعت على العشاء
لما وصلنا المطعم
اطلب منه انه نحط كل اغراضنا وتلفوناتنا
بالكرز
طبعا انا استغربت
انا رايحه اتعشى ليش
اللحظه كنت حابه اتفاجا
فتح باب الاصيل
سكر باب المصعد
وفجاه صارت الدنيا تماما عتمه تماما
لم اعد ارى اي شيء مطلقا وبصراحه ما كنت
مهيا لهذا الموضوع
انا بخاف من العتمه كيف يعني ما بزبط
شعرك بخوف شويه الصبيه
ياللي بيشتغل مطلقا
مشينا ودلتنا كل واحد على طاولته وقعدت كل
واحد على الكرسي تبعه وشرحت لنا شو موجود
على الطاوله قدامنا
الوحده الاولى انا صابني حالي من الصمت
والتشتت تماما صراحه انا اقول لكم حسيت
انه كل شعوري
بالاستقلاليه واعتمادي على حالي عم يتبعثر
يعني انا مش نسرين
غمضت عيني شوي
انا مش شايفه المطعم عباره عن ثواب ظلام
دامس ما ممكن تشوف في اي شيء
قلت لحالي بتعرفي نسرين هي اكثر لحظه تحرر
ممكن تعيشيها مش مهم شو لابسه مش مهم شكلك
مش مهم شو الوانك مش مهم كيف قاعده مش مهم
كيف راح تاكلي بالشوكه بالسكين ولا بايدك
لانه ما في حدا شايفك
ونصاب كل تركي اللحظه على الاحاديث اللي
احنا كمجموعه قاعدين على الطاوله عم نحكي
فيها
ولاحظت انه احاديثنا واحنا مش شايفين بعض
اصبحت اكثر عمقا واسراء واقل تكلفا مما لو
بنحكيها واحنا شايفين بعض
اصبحت كل ارائنا وافكارنا غير محكومه لا
باحكام ولا بافتراضات مسبقه تمليها علينا
اشكالنا لبسنا والواننا طريقه قعدتنا
تصرفاتنا
كان الشيء الوحيد اللي بجمعنا بهذيك
اللحظه انه كلنا عم نعيش لحظات في عالم
خالي من القيود وخالي من الالوان الزائفه
وهديك اللحظه لليوم بحفظ انا بصوره من هذا
النوع لانها معبره جدا
هلا بسال حالي الاسئله التاليه
شو يعني نورمال
شو يعني
وكيف ممكن المجتمع يصنف شخص انه هو معاق
بناء على عجز ما في جسمه حصل لسبب ماء في
وقت ما مش بناء على امكانيه وقدرات يملك
هؤلاء الاشخاص قد لا نملك نحن الذين نصنف
كاصحاء طبيعيه في المجتمع
اليوم
يصادف اليوم العالمي للاشخاص ذو
الاحتياجات الخاصه
هل تعلمون يوجد مليار شخص في العالم يعاني
من شكل من اشكال الاعاقه وهذا يعني واحد
من سبعه او ثمانيه اشخاص في العالم ما
يمثل نسبه 15% من سكان العالم
في فلسطين عندهم نسبه الاشخاص اللي
بيعانوا من حاله حاله خاصه او اكثر 6%
واذا اخذنا حسب الاحصائيات المفهوم الابيض
لا معنى الاعاقه انه اعاقه تامه او شبه
تامه بتوصل للناس بلا اثنين بالميه وقد
تبدو هاي نسبه متدنيا نسبيا ولكنها تمثل
9% من العائلات في فلسطين بالرغم من كل
المحاولات اللي بتصير بكل الدول لدمج
هؤلاء الناس في مجتمعاتهم الا انهم للاسف
ما زالوا يعتبروا طبقه مهمشه
التحديات اللي بتواجه الاشخاص ذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه في فلسطين كثيره
وتتعدد من دمج في سوق العمل من الخدمات
الصحيه من التعليم من المرافق العامه من
البنيه التحتيه ولكن انا اذا بدي اخذ مثال
واحد لانه جدا مهم التعليم اكثر من ثلث
الافراد الاطفال اللي عمرهم فوق ثلاث سنين
لم يلتحقوا بارياض الاطفال
44% من الي عمرهم من سته لتسعه 34% من
عمرهم 10 ل 15
واكثر من
32% من 16 سنه لم يلتحقوا في مدارس واكثر
من 39
اللي عمرهم فوق 16 سنه وهذا مؤشر على ان
نظام التعليم عندنا في فلسطين ما زال غير
قادر
على ابقاء اكبر عدد ممكن من هؤلاء الاطفال
في مرحله التعليم الالزامي في المدارس
السؤال الي بطرح نفسه ليش
ليش نحن بالعالم
ما زال هؤلاء الاشخاص يعتبروا غير مندمجين
في مجتمعاتهم هنالك عده اسباب ولكن
اولا العالم كله بتخطط وبتصمن بناءا على
المنسترين الاغلبيه
السياسه الاغلبيه العادات والتقاليد
الاغلبيه في كل شيء الاغلبيه وبالتالي يتم
تصميم وتخطيط البنيه التحتيه وعالمنا
وحياتنا اليوميه بناء على حاجه
ويتم استثناء هؤلاء الناس وامكانياتهم
قدراتهم من هذا التخطيط اثنين الحكومات
غير قادره على توفير جميع احتياجات هؤلاء
الناس ثلاث القطاع الخاص اكيد
ما عنده هذا الحافظ القوي انه ينتج حلول
لهؤلاء الاشخاص لانه اسعارها رح تطلع كثير
عاليه ماركت الطلب كثير قليل قوتهم
الشرائيه كثير قليله وبالتالي تكلفه
الانتاج عاليه الاسعار راح تطلع عاليه ما
راح يقدروا
واهم جزء في الموضوع المجتمع وانا هون بدي
اقول انه نحن كمجتمع دايما بنلقي لهم على
الحكومات وعلى القطاع الخاص بس ما بنفكر
حالنا في مجتمع اذا باقي المجتمعات العالم
احنا قلنا دور في سد جزء من هذه الفجوه
وين الاف طلاب الجامعات اللي بتخرجوا كل
سنه اليوم دكتور محمد ذكر اعداد المهندسين
عمل كل سنه وين بتروح كيف نستفيد منها شو
بنعمل فيها
لو جينا اخذنا المجتمع ورحنا على حال من
الحلول كابروش قلنا عندنا اول شيء الاشخاص
ذو الاحتياجات الخاصه هم اقدر ناس على
معرفه حاجتهم وهم اهم اهم ناس لازم يكونوا
جزء من عمليه تطوير اي منتج خاص فيهم
بيضاويه
[تصفيق]
ثلاثه ميكر سبيسز كل مراكز التاهيل في
البلد الجامعات المدارس المفروض في عندها
بيسك وورك شوب فيها بيسك 2 واذا لا هذا
اربعه
مراكز التاهيل والجمعيات والمؤسسات التي
تعمل
ركز هون خطين تحت الانديوزرز
اذا نحن عملنا انشطه مجتمعيه مختلفه
وجميعنا فيها هدول الناس وعملنا تصاميم
محدده لحاجه محدده لشخص ذوي حاجه محدده
وكان هو جزء من تطوير هذا
باقل التكاليف وابسط المواد المهندسين
وفي كثير اكزامبلز والحلول ممكن تكون
بما يتناسب مع حاجه كل شخص واذا الشخص
عنده
ولكن
تستخدم من قبل الاخرين
المفروض تفيد المجتمع الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
لا يتجاوز 50 60 دولار
بينما
من شركه عالميه تصنع لطفل عمره سنين
ست تستخدم قشرت تعرفوا قشاره البطاطا
والخضار هاي اللي بالبيت نستخدمها فقدت
اصابيعها زوجها كيف فيني اطول اداه ساعدها
طور شيء كثير سمبل هلا في شركه بالعالم
ويستخدم من قبل الناس المبتورين الاصابع
والناس العاديين في بيوتهم
في شغله اخيره حابه اقولها انه حتى سلوك
المجتمع ممكن يتغير بشغلات بسيطه
في الساين المعروف اللي بنعرفها للشخص
الجزائري بنت لمواقف سيارات في المناطق
العامه اللي بتبين هذا الشخص التاسع
وفي حركه عالميه هلا بطالب
يطبق في بعض الدول اللي بتورجيك الشخص على
الويت شير اكنه عم بركض عم بتحرك الا لما
نحنا نشوف هاي الساين مش هاي الساين نعرف
انه هو انت باندا
كيف الوز بشرنيد
اي بلد
[تصفيق]
اجتماعي
واخلاقي هو واجب اقتصادي ايضا منظمه العمل
الدوليه
انه استثناء الاشخاص ذو الاحتياجات الخاصه
من سوق العمل يسلب هذه الدول ما يقارب
سبعه بالمئه من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
اذا الموضوع مش من باب المساواه والعداله
فقط هو كمان من باب الاستثمار في البلد من
قبل شريحه البلد عم تستثنيها
الاعاقه يا جماعه مش في شخص فقط
الاعاقه قد تكون في القوانين والسياسات
والاجراءات
والبيروقراطيات المفرطه اللي ممكن تثبت كل
قدره عند حدا فينا وتجعلنا كلنا معاقين
فانا الاوان انه نفتح نلتقي نفتح الابواب
للابداعات للشباب للافكار الخلاقه اللي
موجوده في كل شرائح المجتمع والا
سيصيب الشلل التام شغف الكثيرين منه في
هذا البلد شكرا
[تصفيق]